من وجهة نظري ، ستستمر هذه المتغيرات في الظهور ، فأنا أحد الأشخاص الذين يعتقدون أن المتغيرات ستتبدد في تأثيرها بمرور الوقت حيث بدأ سكان العالم يصبحون أكثر حصانة ضد كل ذلك ما لم يكن هناك نوع من السلالة الشريرة حقًا الذي يخرج وقد أقول إنه سيموت موتًا طبيعيًا ولكن اختصاصي اللقاحات سيخبرك أنه في النهاية من المحتمل أن يصبح مجرد فيروس شبيه بالإنفلونزا والذي آمل أن أقول هذا فقط لأنه بالتأكيد يخدم أنفسنا يجب أن يكون هذا هو الحال بالنسبة لصناعة الطيران لكي تبدأ مرة أخرى وأن تعيد الحكومات فتح حدودها للسماح بالسفر ليكون جيدًا وقويًا كما كان قبل جائحة الطمع ، وهو ما نكتشفه أن الدول تتخذ مواقف كما لو كان متغير دلتا ، وبالتالي فهم متشددون إلى حد ما على المدى القصير أعتقد وبعد ذلك عندما يصبح واضحًا ، آمل ألا يكون هذا المتغير فعّالًا في تأثيره على السكان لدرجة أنهم  سوف نخفف القواعد وسيصبح الناس
أكثر استعدادًا لإجراء
الحجوزات والسفر ،
لذلك على خلفية عودة
الطلب بعد التعامل مع
متغير دلتا
أه
كان هذا يعتبر انتكاسة محتملة
من حيث ما نحن  سأفعل ذلك في
الأشهر القليلة القادمة حتى في ديسمبر
بالطبع قوي جدًا لدبي ،
لست مقتنعًا بأننا بحاجة إلى
القلق حيال ذلك ،
فهناك أشخاص لديهم مخاوف حقيقية
بشأن التطعيمات ويجب عليك
احترام ذلك وإيجاد  طريقة للتعامل مع
أنه من الصعب للغاية
أه التعامل معها ولكن حقيقة الأمر
أن هؤلاء
يبدو أن درع برنامج التطعيم
يعمل ضد هذه
المجموعة المعينة من المتغيرات ومن المحتمل برأيي
أن شركات الأدوية
البحث الطبي الذي تم إجراؤه مع
أكبر العقول
في العالم اليوم يعملون جميعًا على
نفس الشيء في نفس الوقت من
المحتمل أننا سننتج المزيد من
اللقاحات التي تحتوي على AG
درجة فاعلية أكثر من بعض
أسلافهم بعد كل هذه الأيام الأولى ،
لذلك أنا واثق من أن هذا الدرع
سوف يزداد قوة بمرور الوقت
لأكون صادقًا تمامًا ، سأقوم بالتخلص من جميع أجهزة الكمبيوتر الشخصي تمامًا سأقول ببساطة
أنه إذا كان بإمكانك إثبات  أنك
تلقيت لقاحين أو ثلاثة لقاحات
ضد التطعيمات
المعترف بها من قبل منظمة الصحة العالمية
وباستخدامها ، ويمكننا بشكل تلقائي
رقمنة هذه العملية كمجتمع
يجب أن يكون جيدًا بما فيه الكفاية بعد كل
شيء لن تحمي الجميع أبدًا
ضد أي شيء وبعد
كل شيء كنا نعيش مع المتغيرات والفيروسات الشبيهة بالإنفلونزا
منذ
آلاف السنين بصراحة
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنك تعلم أنني
أحد هؤلاء المديرين قد توصلوا إليه
سواء في شركتي السابقة أو في
الإمارات في عام 1985 ، كنا
توسعيًا
لقد عملنا على التوسع بوتيرة
كبيرة ، فقد استقطبنا أعدادًا كبيرة من الأشخاص من
جميع أنحاء العالم من جميع المهارات
ومهما كانت  فكرة بعد 30 عامًا غريبًا من
القيام بذلك 35 عامًا أنه سيتعين
علينا البدء في طردهم دون أي خطأ
من جانبهم ،
لقد كان شيئًا جديدًا بالنسبة
لنا جميعًا وكان على الأرجح التحدي الأكبر
الذي ربما أواجهه
في  مسيرتي المهنية لست معتادًا على تسريح
الأشخاص ، إنها ليست
أمرًا فظيعًا أم
أنها تدمر الروح لمجرد أنه
كان على الأشخاص الطيبين جدًا أن يذهبوا دون أي خطأ من
جانبهم ، لكننا قلنا دائمًا
وكنا نعتقد دائمًا أننا
سنعيد العملية
في  امتلاء الوقت لم يكن هناك أبدًا
أي سؤال مفاده أن هذا كان
تحولًا نموذجيًا لتقليص حجم العمل
وإعادة النظر في النموذج وما إلى ذلك ، كنا نعلم دائمًا
أننا سنعيده إلى حيث
كان وننموه بالسرعة التي كنا
نفعلها دائمًا مما يعني ذلك
كتعزية  إذا كان هناك واحد عرفناه
أننا سنقوم بإعادة الناس ،
لكن ذلك لم يساعدهم
الذين اضطروا إلى الاستغناء عن وظائفهم وفقدوا مصادر رزقهم
وجميع الأجزاء والأجزاء الأخرى التي تصاحبها ،
كان الأمر صعبًا على
الجميع ولكن
لقد نجحنا ، وكما قلت بحق ، فإننا نعيد
الآن أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص
بأسرع ما يمكن
[موسيقى]
كل ما أود قوله هو أن
أرباحنا الأسبوعية
تتضاعف أسبوعيًا ،
ويسعدنا جدًا أن
إنتاجنا يصل إلى حوالي
65 70 من المكان الذي كان عليه قبل أن لا يزال
لدينا عدد من 380s جالسًا على
الأرض وهذا مدفوع بشكل أساسي بحقيقة
أننا لا نستطيع الحصول على الطيارين في الطاقم
في المحيط الهادئ الذي نرغب في
أن نعيد تدريبه أيضًا  لذلك نحن لا
نتنازل عن أي زوايا أو نقطعها
للتأكد من أن لدينا سلامة التشغيل
مع عملياتنا ،
لذا
فإن الدخل يرتفع بسرعة كبيرة
، كانت البضائع
شريان حياتنا على مدار الأشهر
القليلة الماضية أه الماضية 18 شهرًا في الواقع
ولا يزال هذا مستمراً للغاية  قوي حتى
ترتفع الأرباح ،
لقد تم
تحييد عامل البناء النقدي
وبدأنا في إعادة بناء مركزنا النقدي ، وهو
أمر مهم للغاية لميزانيتنا العمومية
، وبينما كان لدينا صافي حرق مرتفع للغاية
كل شهر تم
إيقافه ونحن الآن نعيد بناء
ذلك  الإئتمان  إلى كل شخص قام
بالمهمة ، لذا
عبرت أصابعنا ،
فنحن في حالة أفضل بكثير مما
كنا نعتقد أنه ربما قبل عام ،
لكننا لم نصدق أبدًا أننا لن
نكون بهذا الشكل في وقت ما في
الستة أو التسعة المقبلة.  أشهر لذلك كل شيء يسير
وفقًا للخطة